one of the characteristics that doesn't  get talked about a lot for entrepreneurs  is curiosity across industries that are  not even related to your domain I tended  to be curious about almost everything  about science about technology etc and  found in my life that patterns I have  found in computational fluid dynamics  actually applied to you know  computational chemistry or computational  chemistry stuff and docking and folding  was applicable to finite element  analysis or you know material science or  something else that's just the curiosity  and pattern part but I just think  epiphanies come from having a constant  stream of data flowing in and I'm almost  like a neural net running in the  background that just one day pops out of  a side of your head that's clearly  processing in the background and  literally will come out  you